Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
J'ai fait un peu de rangement ce matin.
Ça, il faut que je m'en débarrasse.
Enfin, ce ne sera pas perdu pour tout le monde.
Vous le savez, les déchets se trient,
ils ont une seconde vie
et ce geste est de plus en plus simple.
C'est écrit dessus
Le problème
avec nos déchets, c'est que parfois nous ne savons pas où les déposer.
3 Français sur 4 avouent se retrouver régulièrement
dans cette situation avec les emballages.
Pour certains produits,
on ne se pose pas la question.
Ce pot de confiture, par exemple, à l'exception
du couvercle, va atterrir dans le bac de collecte du verre.
Ce matériau est entièrement recyclable autant de fois que l'on veut.
Pour 6 Français sur 10 c'est même devenu un réflexe.
Du coup, 85% du verre est collecté et recyclé aujourd'hui.
Il est fondu et à nouveau utilisé pour fabriquer
du verre que l'on pourra recycler.
Mais parfois, c'est un peu plus compliqué.
Ce paquet de céréales, par exemple
en carton, avec un sachet plastique à l'intérieur
cette peluche ou encore ce vieux tee-shirt, qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ?
Ne vous prenez plus la tête,
Triman et ses consignes de tri vont vous aider.
Cette signalétique, prévue par la loi anti-gaspillage de 2020, figurera
d'ici la fin 2023 sur la plupart des produits que nous consommons.
Bien visibles,
Triman et son cartouche info-tri indiquent les consignes de tri.
Ils figurent sur le produit, sur l'emballage, sur le mode d'emploi
ou sur le site web du fabricant.
C'est très clair, il n'y a qu'à se laisser guider.
Voyons ça ensemble.
Une canette de soda.
L'info figure sur l'emballage.
Le tri nous indique qu'elle doit être déposée dans le bac de tri.
La boîte de céréales,
l'info-tri précise exactement ce qu'il
faut faire de la boîte et du sachet.
Le carton au tri et le sachet en plastique également, en veillant
à bien les séparer pour faciliter leur traitement.
La peluche maintenant,
elle ne doit pas être déposée avec les emballages plastiques
ni avec les déchets ordinaires.
Elle peut être donnée si elle est encore en bon état.
Sinon, elle peut être rapportée dans un bac dédié
dans les magasins de jouets
qui en organisent désormais la collecte
ou bien déposés en déchetterie.
Quant à ce T-shirt
devenu un peu trop petit, vous avez le choix :
maigrir,
mais vous pouvez aussi le donner à un proche,
le revendre sur une plateforme
ou bien le déposer dans une borne de collecte des textiles
ou le donner à une association solidaire.
Mais ce n'est pas pour la poubelle ordinaire.
Vous le voyez,
avec le Triman et son cartouche d'info-tri,
il n'y a plus d'hésitation.
Et si le tri man et l'info-tri
ne figurent plus sur le produit,
que vous n'avez plus l'emballage,
ou que vous avez un doute, vous trouverez toutes les infos sur le site :
Que devient ce paquet de céréales
une fois collecté dans le bac de tri ?
Son carton, tout comme les journaux et les vieux magazines,
les boîtes à chaussures,
les briques de lait.
Ce carton, donc, est recyclé.
On le transforme en pâte à papier.
Plus d'un million de tonnes de papier et
carton usagé sont collectées en France
chaque année grâce aux gestes de tri.
Avec on fabrique des emballages,
du papier cadeau, des journaux et des livres, du papier essuie-tout.
Une fibre de papier peut être réutilisée 5 à 7 fois.
Chaque année, le recyclage des papiers permet d'économiser
19 milliards de litres d'eau.
C'est l'équivalent de 6400 piscines olympiques
Pour le sachet plastique, c'est un peu plus compliqué.
Tout dépend de sa composition.
Les plastiques qui se recyclent bien, comme
le polyéthylène de cette bouteille de lait, sont broyés.
Ils sont transformés en granulés qui serviront à fabriquer
de nouvelles bouteilles, des bacs à fleurs
et même des pièces automobiles.
Et s'ils ne peuvent pas être recyclés,
les plastiques sont incinérés dans une usine dédiée.
Cette opération permet de produire de l'électricité
ou de la chaleur pour les collectivités.
Trier ses déchets plastiques
limite aussi la pollution et notamment dans les océans.
Plus de la moitié des déchets en haute mer sont des plastiques.
Franchement, mieux vaut les voir atterrir dans le bac de tri.
Protéger la planète avec le tri :
Yes we can !
Comme les boîtes de conserves,
les canettes sont constituées d'acier ou d'aluminium
100% recyclable et à l'infini.
En les triant, on limite l'extraction de minerai.
Cette canette sera fondue pour récupérer son métal
dont on fera une canette ou une boîte de conserve toute neuve.
Des clés, des montants de fenêtre,
des boules de pétanque.
680 canettes comme celle-ci, recyclées,
et vous vous offrez un cadre de vélo.
Enfin, ce tee-shirt
même s'il ne sert plus ici, grâce au tri,
il sera utile ailleurs.
Plus de la moitié des textiles collectés entament une seconde vie.
Vendu ou donné,
il continue d'être porté.
Déposez-le, comme les chaussures
et le linge de maison, dans une borne dédiée
ou directement auprès d'une association solidaire.
Ce geste permet d'éviter les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
liées à la fabrication d'un produit similaire.
Entre sa conception et son arrivée dans votre armoire,
un jean, par exemple, parcourt en moyenne
65000 kilomètres, soit une fois et demie le tour de la Terre.
Et puis,
si votre vêtement est malheureusement trop abîmé pour être reporté,
sa collecte permettra de valoriser ses fibres.
Déchiquetés et compactés en rouleaux,
elles peuvent faire un très bon isolant pour les bâtiments.
Je commence à avoir la fibre du tri, moi.
Tant mieux.
Aujourd'hui, il existe déjà une quinzaine de filières de produits
pour lesquelles un système de collecte séparée des déchets est organisé.
Les emballages et les papiers à déposer dans les bacs de tri.
Les textiles à apporter en borne
ou à donner à des associations.
Les appareils électroménagers, les piles, les batteries
et les ampoules qui ne doivent en aucun cas
être jetés dans la poubelle ordinaire.
Ils renferment des produits chimiques polluants et doivent être
rapportés en bornes dédiées en magasin ou à la déchetterie.
Ils sont presque entièrement recyclés.
Les médicaments qui renferment des principes actifs
peuvent être déposés à la pharmacie.
Et les produits dangereux tels que les huiles de vidange,
déposés en déchetterie.
En 2022,
De nouvelles filières sont venues s'ajouter à cette liste,
comme les jouets,
les produits de bricolage et de sport qui doivent maintenant
être rapportés dans les magasins spécialisés.
D'ici 2025,
il existera au total 23 filières de collecte et de tri.
- Attends, attends, j'arrive pas à tout noter.
- Inutile de prendre des notes.
Triman et son cartouche d'info-tri vous permettent
en un clin d'œil de savoir comment bien les trier le moment venu.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
- Top.
Rien à jeter !
Dans ce cas,
il faut liker et vous abonner, si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
pour rejoindre la communauté des Épicurieuses et des Épicurieux.
À très bientôt.